after a two-hour rain delay at kauffman
stadium we are just about ready to play
baseball game one of this three-game
series between the chicago white sox and
the kansas city royals pitching for the
royals is carlos hernandez he is four
and one and he gets robert to chase a
breaking ball
in the dirt so he went fastball slider
fastball slider
hernandez
brings it home
and strike three call so a fast ball at
the knees
catches mankato looking and dallas kikel
is on the bump 26th start of the season
you saw the quote that we showed you
earlier in the day and you know about
what dallas is about
there's nikki lopez
[Applause]
you were saying something about the
defense
give me that
go grab some pine
good try not good enough that's a nice
play boy that that ball was rocking it
too look at those hops
like a little basketball player i'm
gonna need to check to see if you can
play some hooves back in the day well
you know about timing and how hard of a
play that is
for jimenez
since his late july debut coming back
from the pectoral injury
there's a 1-1
hard hit to right goal
that's what the stocks need right there
get some runners on base
and now another one of their
good-looking prospects
gavin sheets
and then he gets him with a 99 mile an
hour fastball
edward olivares who's sitting in the
cleanup spot
down low a lead off walk to a speed guy
carlos antenna the royals trying to get
him unlocked
and he hits one sharply into left field
so the royals with a good start much
like the white sox two on nobody out in
the second inning let's see what the
royals can do let's see if michael a
taylor can come through against dallas
kykel
and he does and a ground ball to short
the run will score out at first as
taylor but the royals get olivares home
and a one-nothing royal lead here's ben
attendee andrew's been fighting himself
a little bit he's three for his last 33
and that's why mike matheny against the
lefty and the mound dropped him to the
eight spot
he does go to the gap right center field
and ravon
will not get there and ben and tendy
planted exactly where we talked about
he's going for three and we'll make it
with a triple
we talked about robert the center
fielder playing him to the left field
and he got underneath it and it ball
didn't it just plugged watch it look at
that he's hitting that wet grass right
there and that backed up on vaughn and
he was able to get three with no problem
in an uh rbi attached tota struck out
looking on a fastball his first timeout
and a fastball lifted to center
extends the hitting streak it's a
career-high
17-game hit streak for johan monkatta
kaikou will now face number two hitter
nikki lopez
second walk of the ball game for kykel
that's not like him he usually has
outstanding command and the royals have
one of the very best in all of baseball
and salvador perez
shot to left field and for salvador
perez he ties eric hosmer for 10th in
royals history with
1132 hits
now let's see what edward olivares can
do bases this year does not go and that
ball's rolled up to left field here
comes lopez around third they're going
to hold him and the ball is thrown way
high he would have scored easily alberto
has an extra base hit in five straight
games that's a career best for him
back up the middle
and then comes lopez here comes salvador
perez the ball bobbled and everybody's
gonna score
he's a difference maker and i told you
about his hands he's a very handsy type
hitter and he's he knows the game
he says i'm just going to put it in play
look at that all hands there
[Applause]
i like it you got a little little
emotion
you you don't see that kind of emotion
from monday and robert looked up before
he caught the ball
taylor may be his last batter
and michael a hits it to left field and
modesty scores in six nothing royals
change up just doesn't have the location
where he wants it that's out over the
middle of the plate michael lake quick
quick hands
salvador perez the batter
matt foster
begins his second inning of work
and now salvi goes to the gap
right center field
perez is two for three carlos santana
the d.h tonight switch hitter batting
left-handed open stance
heads sharply to right
perez around second he's going for third
throw by vaughn
they can't catch the guy as fast as
salvi come on salvi looks fresh here's
michael a
and then he singles to left field what a
great at-bat by michael a taylor
to face the lefty hitting ben attendee
who has a rbi triple and a double
tonight
it's knocked down but they won't get
anybody give him a hit the bases will be
loaded give him a hit
it's it's willie mays yeah i think he
was the most electric player
good pitch and a fastball strike
[Applause]
three four and five here in the sixth it
is abreu jimenez and grandal
on the ground and through a base hit to
left to open up the sixth
perform well at times
although hernandez has put the first two
men on base here in the sixth garcia
trying to keep the line moving with a
man at third and try to get the socks on
the board
first pitch
that'll score a run hernandez will get
the outlet
abreu scores it's an rbi for garcia and
it's 7-1 1-2 to sheets
lifted in the air
long run for monday and for bennett
[Music]
[Applause]
crosses and it's seven to two it was
almost like they were waiting for
one of the others
now tyler zuber comes out of the royals
bullpen
romey gonzalez
to the right side whittle take care of
it
and the royals do have the victory their
60th this year
7-2 the final score as they beat the
americans league central leading
chicago white sox benintendi quite a
game fill a home run short of the cycle